euro Max lifestyle Europe and here's
your host a no Donald hello and welcome
to your max meets nd in store for you
today let's have a look at what's coming
up in the next 30 minutes on their own
way
a young romanian designer debuts a
brilliant fashion week in the depth we
all knew a is one of the world's top
free divers and in the lake while
various Rose Island is a popular tourist
magnet but it's brilliant fashion week
here so Yura max decided to profile some
of the standout designers last year
junior designer johanna choukaku mehron
from Romania won the coveted designer
for tomorrow price awarded by Stella
McCartney well as part of the awards
Mirren also got her own fashion show at
Fashion Week that and a lot more we went
along to check out her collection and
see how the young talent award has held
the romanians career
romanian designer johanna chela COO at a
fitting for her debut Fashion Show in
Berlin Shalaka calls her collection
hunters and it's 25 designs reflect the
interaction between hunter and prey the
cornerstone of this collection was laid
a year ago when chilaka won the designer
for tomorrow prize at Berlin Fashion
Week actually is one year and five days
yes yeah I remember of course it was my
first big fitting and it was hectic
because we kept switching models I mean
it's the same number this more relaxed
because I already have the experience so
I'm more relaxed one year ago Shalaka
was one of five finalists for the
designer for tomorrow award chosen from
a pool of 350 applicants British fashion
designer Stella McCartney was the
competition's patron
and in the end McCartney and the panel
of fashion experts chose gelato and her
paradox collection as the winner she
just really sort of had a great point of
view and a lovely silhouette quite
architectural quite a statement but at
the same time quite wearable and I think
that's kind of what I'm looking for in
these kind of things somebody that's
really new in the way that they approach
design but also at the same time
somebody that you you feel you want to
wear the award provided Shalako with
financial support and assistance in
establishing her own label
she's now opened her own studio in the
Romanian capital Bucharest Shalako
accompanied McCartney and her team when
they put on a show at Paris Fashion Week
and she visited the British designer at
her studio in London
it wasn't any more advice regarding
design which you knows best because I
think that she she thinks that I'm
prepared already so it was more of a
industry import you know how business
works you know that's why I visited her
studio because I opened my studio so you
know I wanted to know what's the level
of how many people are they you know how
they work how do they manage everything
so that was more important designer for
tomorrow winners also get the chance to
stage their own show at Berlin Fashion
Week the models the PR the health
backstage they've all been organized for
you on a chilaka
the young designer hopes to take the
fashion world by storm from her
headquarters in Bucharest she plans to
produce her collection in Romania as
well it's her way of supporting her
country's economy and ensuring good
quality
these are moment it's like this moment
in time is slow compared to what's
coming next
meaning that things are getting quicker
and more global not under the manner
markets are opening up is being thank
you so I think this point of view is the
right one these days designers can stay
where they are and still communicate
with the whole world
like maybe at some stage will no longer
need venues like Fashion Week but find
completely different platforms so people
should start off where they feel most
comfortable
European a clothing store chain peak and
Cloppenburg Dusseldorf has been
sponsoring the designer for tomorrow
competitions since 2009 the patron of
this year's competition is the American
designer Tommy Hilfiger jalaja show
kicks off the finale
and there's still time for her to enjoy
the attention and support that's on
offer before she has to stand on her own
two feet there has been a lot of
emotions for me I never had so many
emotions in my life because of the you
know winning and the preparations before
and now you know again with the show
again the same feelings but I was grown
up really good so now I have the power
to be on my own I guess after the show
you wanna chill aku is ready to launch
her career as an independent designer
she's no longer a designer for tomorrow
she's creating fashions for today
sign lighting at the latest news and
events happening in Europe if you have
some spare cash and you're looking to
buy a village there is one going for
real cheap up the mountains in Italy and
if that's not your thing then not to
worry because we just happen to have a
street artist that will blow your mind
the first solo exhibition of works by
street artist Phyllis has opened in the
Portuguese capital Lisbon the artist who
also works under his real name Alex on
the photo carves his artwork into the
walls of outdoor buildings often using
pneumatic drills and controlled
explosions his portraits carved out of
several layers of billboard posters won
him fame in his hometown of Lisbon it's
now splits his time between London and
Lisbon an alpine village in the Italian
region of Piedmont has gone up for sale
on eBay the asking price for the village
of Bogota colosseo is two hundred and
forty-five thousand euros over a hundred
users have already expressed their
interest but buyers will have to agree
to certain conditions the village which
has a tiny population and just 14 houses
is in need of restoration
and any developments must stay true to
the villages original character the
European balloon festival drew to a
close in vallata near the Spanish city
of Barcelona on Sunday teams from all
around Europe took part in competition
flights while some 25,000 visitors
joined in the festivities the balloon
festival was first held in 1997 and has
been an annual event ever since it's one
of the largest festivals of its kind in
Europe
well extreme water sports like this next
one will take your breath away quite
literally when you see what guillaume
near a gets up to or rather down to he
is one of the best free divers in the
world and a former world record holder
who hit steps of a hundred and seventeen
meters without an oxygen tank there is
also one of the most creative underwater
filmmakers almost twenty million people
have watched his short youtube video so
we caught up with him and his
videographer to talk about their new
movie images that show the beauty of an
extreme sport one that's always
overshadowed by the specter of death
barely a season goes by without a free
diver dying but for the creators of the
film knockos free diving is simply the
most amazing sport there is another
point of view to what we're adding is we
are not showing we're not showing the
right course or deep diving we're trying
to emphasize on on the beauty of the
sport here in Nice on Frances
Mediterranean coast free divers Julie
Gautier and Guillaume nari
prepare for today's shoot with
stretching and breathing exercises at
100 metres below the water's surface
lungs shrink to the size of two oranges
do breathing exercises while stretching
exercise in order to accept this
pressure the key of Dupree diving is to
relax and accept if you fight against
the pressure you're gonna feel the pain
and it's going to be uncomfortable and
you can urge yourself
the two freedivers have been a couple
for several years
having met through their sport they
branched out into filmmaking four years
ago with their first video free fall
inspired by BASE jumping videos it shows
Guillaume Nerys freefall in Dean's Blue
Hole in the Bahamas
diem was in the Bombers for the
competition
and we had this camera and Sonia we have
a good camera we should make a movie say
okay just take the camera and we made we
made triple that we have now our 18
million views it's just crazy
there internet fans financed the
couple's next project knockos was made
more or less on their own doorstep here
in the Bay of V from Sumer and in the
mountains near the Cote d'Azur the short
film deals with the hallucinations that
free divers can have on very deep dives
the classic rapture of the deep caused
by nitrogen narcosis once Guillaume had
a vision of marrying his girlfriend
visions and the narco seas and the
rupture of the depths are not always
funny sometimes it's kind of scary and
when I'm bit anxious before the dive it
can be a nightmare down there today
they're doing test shots for new videos
Julie Gautier has always been fascinated
by the rapture of the deep though she's
never experienced it herself
it's especially strong during dives of
90 meters or more during their shoots
great depths don't play a role here it's
about their collaboration underwater and
how the lack of heavy diving equipment
makes it special you have a freedom of
movement underwater Julie when she's
filming me she can follow me up and down
she can go at the same speed she can
turn around me and free diving the spots
were diving is freedom so filming on
free diving is filming with freedom
after the test shots the couple head
back to their apartment on the outskirts
of nice where the two-year-old daughter
Malu awaits them this season Guillaume
is taking a break from competitions and
world record attempts one reason for
that is the death last year of an
American free diver the couple want to
use the time for more film projects
waiting price so if we expect too much
we're gonna be disappointed in
expectation even if deep inside the home
and we are like ah we hope is going to
be successful again now COEs has been
screened at various festivals and can
now be viewed online too the couple are
also uploading a video they shot in the
underwater world of French Polynesia
Yura max visited Rose Island on Lake
Starnberg near Munich it's home to a
faithfully restored Rose Garden from the
19th century
for over 60 varieties of roses are in
bloom only one inhabitant lives there
but its beauty and history attracts up
to seventeen thousand visitors a year
Yura max had a ramble about the island
to get an insight into the history and
the rich diversity of the garden Rose
Island on Lake Starnberg it fascinated
the Varian king maximilian ii who
purchased it in 1850 and converted it
into his own personal paradise
he built summer residence as well as
several landscaped gardens his son
ludwig ii was also enchanted by the
island
yah Hudson we had about a thousand rose
bushes planted here to create more
privacy
he loved roses and enjoyed retreating
here again India and some curb silver
caps on Honolulu Akash is a keen
gardener as well as a tour guide she
decided to share her extensive bow Tanic
knowledge by offering tours of the Rose
Garden alone it isn't the freak of
nature it's our very d flora first
bounce is quite unremarkable it looks
nothing like a rose but it is one it's a
green rose and it has a tangy fragrance
on top close it smells a bit like herbs
you'd use for cooking quicken quiter
there are more than 60 different kinds
of roses on the island with the
exception of the green rose they are all
white pink and red some of their names
are particularly intriguing like the
chapeau DiNapoli off for example
from the cesium if we take a look at the
leaves at these sepals here they clearly
resemble Napoleon's tricorn hat that's
where the wonderful name comes from the
special thing about this rose is that
it's a moss rose if you rub it like this
it lets off a really spicy resinous
scent the summer villa on Rose Island is
a popular venue for wedding photos it's
got a very special ambience and a
remarkable history to ludwig ii and
empress elisabeth spent a lot of time
here
but you were very similar in terms of
their thinking and feelings on Ludwig
and Elizabeth loved to retreat here to
enjoy nature and the beauty of the
island to take in the roses and to have
some peace wasn't in such often 'man one
from yoga would so home Rose Island on
Lake Starnberg
a bavarian gem which enchants thousands
of visitors every year
what part of Europe would you most like
to see
every week our euro max extra tour
series takes you to a region or tourist
attraction of your choice in Europe
write in and tell us where you want to
go and why
don't forget your photo then we'll take
an extra tour on your behalf and show
your picture on our program write to us
at DW euro max voltage draw so six one
three three five five Berlin Germany or
send a fax to four nine for Germany
three zero for Berlin four six four six
six five zero five or an email to euro
max English at DW de we're looking
forward to hearing from you
well 3d printing has kicked off a new
era although it seems that certain
spheres of creativity are moving into
surreal territory particularly in the
construction industry well in the
Netherlands one architect and his team
are currently working on printing the
first canal house ever
yes canal house using this six meter
high printer means skipping the basics
like the builders cement and stone so
your max looks at the future of
architecture and visits the Dutch
construction site what looks like a
child's toy at first sight could
potentially revolutionize the building
sector a typical Amsterdam canal house
from a 3d printer the individual
components were made in a specially
designed 3d printer
anything that we're looking for ways to
deal with the world more sustainably
making concrete which is used in the
construction of most buildings produces
a lot of carbon dioxide the material
we're building with could reduce
emissions by 60% percent a granulate
made of linseed oil and plastic is put
into the top of the printer and slowly
heated then a three millimeter thick
plastic thread builds up the walls layer
by layer in all a hundred and thirty
individual components have to be put
together bit by bit to make the
three-story house the idea behind it in
future the architects want to build
houses from plastic bottles if the
buildings are no longer needed the
material could be shredded and recycled
in Amsterdam the project is already
attracting spectators I think some of
its political to make a statement that
you could make something just from a
digital design make something
theoretically that's purely recyclable a
few pieces of furniture was specially
made for visitors so you switch it I
think with the house wet they're working
on that as well a present it takes more
than 40 hours for the printer to make a
single building component the canal
house should be ready in two and a half
years
well markets are a great place to pick
up a bargain and the sample the local
produce and they have become
increasingly popular for tourists
because they're seen as a reflection of
a places traditions and lifestyle so
this week we are going to explore some
of Europe's best-known markets and start
off your Max is heading to the northern
city of Hamburg renowned for its
historical and traditional fish market
an entertaining outing but you have to
get there early for the full experience
it's 3:30 on a Sunday morning in Hamburg
the vendor is at the fish market are
preparing for the day's work and the
first customers have already arrived
even though the market hasn't officially
opened yet some 700 retailers have
stands here every Sunday
at four o'clock Germany's best-known
market crier DITA boon arrives the fish
market has a special Flair from
university professors to laborers
everyone beats up here it's a real
meeting spot and it's quite an
entertaining place where the market
Criers we have here and a fresh fish
bidding Donson fish fish
five o'clock the market is open for
business
on a good day some 70,000 visitors come
here a cafe next to the market
seed everyone is enjoying a bit of calm
before the storm soon he'll take his
place
at center stage
smoke deland wild salmon artists
specialties as soon as the stand opens
the shoppers are waiting and looking
forward to being entertained moon is one
of the most colorful characters at the
market and an institution in his own
right
sales patter is all part of the
experience
didja trained as a mechanical engineer
but found his true calling as a
fishmonger he used to sell fish at
markets during the week - I love
interacting with people at helping
people man they enjoy the chance to
laugh they enjoy my jokes
Thank You Mimi that's
at 7:00 a.m. the crowds have arrived
some early arrivals are heading home
from a night on the town locals tourists
even the fishmongers they all love this
Sunday morning market
we thought we'd round things off with a
visit to the fish market we often come
here when we've been out partying we
just go and grab a fish roll and Samael
it's a bit like a show we've got
relatives staying right now this is my
sister this is a professor from Ukraine
we're here so they can see the show the
are tuna fish market has been a local
landmark since 17:03 back then the fish
was supposed to be sold before everyone
went to church and sleep early start
today visitors can also buy souvenirs
flowers fruit and sweet treats the fish
vendors love entertaining their visitors
they're famous for their banter and for
their loud voices it's more relaxed here
than the usual weekday markets everyone
hears on first-name terms in a good mood
it's a traditional market and it's good
fun we get all the night owls we get
tourists we all joke around it's a good
laugh at eight o'clock it's already
pouring rain as is often the case in
Hamburg the crowds are heading to the
fish auction Hall next to the market on
Sundays it becomes a makeshift Fun Fair
there's even live music
resembling a three nave basilica the
hall was built in 1895 and first opened
in 1896
back then the catch was auctioned off
every morning fresh off the boats the
atmosphere is a little different today
despite the weather DITA is doing a
roaring trade as you can see the rain
doesn't put anyone off I've had loads of
customers it was fine
never mind the rain it's 10:00 in the
morning and his working day is over how
much did he sell today that's a secret
DITA Bonin's off home to his wife and
lunch of roast duck but he'll be back
next week same time same place just as
he has been for more than 50 years
that's all we have time for today thanks
for watching and if you missed any of
our reports then catch up online see you
soon
next time on euro max the French city of
Klaus has a very special royal
connection because many of the kings of
France were crowned in its nut hood dom
cathedral declared a UNESCO World
Heritage Site in 1991 the city is also
famed as a center of champagne
production this and or next time on yo
max
you